relates to where the Muslims should pray
their Eid prayer is it compulsory for
them to pray it at the Ida or are they
allowed to pray it in the mosques too as
far as the Sunnah of the Prophet is
concerned Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasam
he always commanded that as far as each
Salah is concerned of both the it should
be offered in the Mah it should be
offered in the Ida Ida is the word used
in India Pakistan the Arabic word is
musah it's mainly an open ground so that
more people can gather so one town or
one city they should be as least
Gathering as possible and bigger
Gathering so it should be one musah mean
one place where a person prays for the
full Town that's preferable or as least
number of places maximum number of
gathering let's mention the Hadith of
say bukari volum number two in the book
of to Hadi number
956 it says the prophet during the the E
day he went and prayed in the Mah and
there are various Hadith which we
discussed earlier that in say
bukari volume number one Hadith number
324 the prophet commanded the wom the
children the menstruating women to go to
pray in Thea according to the IM IM Abu
hanifah Imam Malik and Imam ammed may
Allah have mercy on them all all of
themselves that going to the Ida is a
requirement it's a must unless there's a
necessity except for Imam Shafi may
Allah have mercy on him Imam shaffi he
said that if the mosque is Big to
accommodate all the people then you
can't pray in the mosque but even he
said if the mosque is not book to accomm
all the people then preferable
isah that so the preferable thing is and
the prophet for the Salah even though
the general ruling is according
[Music]
tokari volume
number two in the book of priorities of
praying in the MJ Makkah and Madina
Hadith number 11 190 the prophet said
that praying in my mosque m is a
thousand times better than praying in
any other mosque except mid Haram M
Makkah in spite of this he preferred
that show the superiority during each
Salah only and unfortunately nowadays
most part of the world hardly we find
there are people who praying in grounds
but very few what we should have is one
Place can't we have one big park for the
each Salah and all pray together or hire
two parks in the full City and gather
all the Muslims together unfortunately
we don't have that even in Bombay there
are very few places where they offer in
big grounds but majority are in the
mosque so preferbly it should be in a
ground as less number of places to pray
and bigger the Gathering it should be
unless there is a requirement where thei
in Al the book of Hadith number 109 for
one day during Eid because it was
raining the prophet prayed in the mosque
so if there is a reason like raining
snowing Etc and then you pray in the
mosque it's fine otherwise it's
preferable pray in theka